ANNA CAVENDER: Thank you
everybody for joining us today.
I'm really excited to welcome
our Lieutenant Governor, Cyrus
Habib.
As lieutenant governor, he
presides over the State Senate
and he serves as acting governor
when the governor is out
of town.
And he's passionate
about several issues,
including veterans and
disability employment,
economic development, access
to higher education, trade,
and international relations.
Prior to being elected
as lieutenant governor,
he served on both the State
Senate and the State House
of Representatives,
and he has a law degree
from Yale Law School.
And he's done all of this while
overcoming many obstacles.
He's a self-described
three-time cancer survivor,
blind Iranian American from
a mixed-religion immigrant
family.
So really excited to
have him here today.
Thank you so much
for visiting us.
I'll let you take it away.
CYRUS HABIB: Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks so much.
Well, it's wonderful to be here.
Part of what I guess didn't
make its way into my bio
is that I'm also a former
Googler, although only briefly.
I never made it out
of my Newgler phase.
I was an intern in the London
office of Google sales intern
the summer between my first
and second years in law
school working on Middle
Eastern and North African sales.
I have a ton of first decade
Google swag to show for it.
And actually, it was exactly
10 years ago this year.
So it's wonderful
to be here with you
guys to talk about
accessibility.
I want to give you a
bit of framing around
why I'm personally passionate
about this issue, why
I care about it, why
I'm grateful to you
all for caring about it.
As you heard, I am the son
of immigrants from Iran.
My parents came here in search
of economic and educational
opportunities.
Shortly after I was born, I was
diagnosed with a rare childhood
eye cancer that took my eyesight
in my left eye as a newborn
and then came back again
and left me completely
blind at age eight years old.
And I often joke that because
that happened in 1989, that's
when I was eight years old.
So all eight years
that I could see
actually took place
within the 1980s,
so all my visual memories
are still from the '80s.
So everyone still looks like
Cindy Lauper and Boy George.
We moved from Maryland where
I'd grown up to that point
to Washington state.
And thanks to a combination
of parents who really believed
in me and believed in my ability
to fulfill my own potential
as well as relatively
well-resourced public schools
here on the east side of King
County and some extraordinary
teachers who had a big
effect in my life--
and as you'll hear in
a moment, thanks also
to some technologies--
and of course, thanks to
meaningful public policy
and laws, I was able to
travel the road from Braille
to Yale and beyond.
So when I think
about technology,
I had the great pleasure of
representing this district
in the state legislature.
So in addition to
this campus, I also
represented Microsoft's
headquarters.
Around the world,
I say I may just
be a state legislator, what
other person in the state
legislature could
ever say that they
represent the two wealthiest
people on the planet?
But more than the
two of them, it
was and continues to be
of particular interest
and privilege for me to be able
to represent the future Bezos
and Gateses, the
future Pages and Brins,
and essentially
the entrepreneurs
and innovators of the future
who may not be famous yet
and certainly may be
in this room right now.
That's really what
is exciting to me.
And I'll tell you why
technology has always
been-- because even
before I was a legislator,
I practiced law at
Perkins Coie in Seattle
where I represented startups
and help technology companies
with licensing issues
and in other early stage
corporate matters.
The reason it's always
been of interest to me
is that when you
have a disability,
you've got this kind
of special relationship
with technology,
which is that you're
in a ever iterating cycle of
being disrupted by technology
and then having technology
then come to the rescue.
And to some degree, that's not
unlike our general condition
as a human race, but
it's particularly
pronounced for people
with disabilities.
So to take the IT
or ICT context--
so when I was a kid, I
wasn't the nerdiest kid.
There are definitely nerdier
people in the room right now,
but I was into computers.
Growing up in this area,
a lot of my friends
were kids of
Microsofties and stuff,
so I grew up around computers.
I remember the
first computer I had
was a 486 and running
DOS primarily.
And if you're blind,
DOS was the golden age--
command line interface,
just so easy, right?
There's a screen
reading software.
And so it's great.
You can copy files.
You can find out what's in
the directory that you're in.
You can move around to
different directories.
I think you all
knew, but directories
are what we called folders
before they were folders.
And so you could do all kinds
of things that seemed impressive
at the time.
And then Windows 3.1
and Windows 95 came out,
and I was just
starting high school.
And that wasn't so good
for people who were blind,
because graphical user
interfaces by definition
were not made for blind
people first and foremost.
So there was this whole
setback and disruption.
I could still use DOS,
but nothing interesting
was happening in DOS anymore.
No one was making
applications for DOS.
So I got pretty frustrated.
I loved command line interfaces.
So I was like, you know what?
My friend taught me about Linux.
And I was like, I'm going
to learn how to use Linux.
But the problem with Linux was
that there was no real screen
reader for Linux.
There were some weird
solutions that people had,
but there was no screen
reader that just ran
on top of the operating system.
So what I devised with
a friend was this kind
of dummy terminal running DOS--
a terminal that was like a--
I think it was a 386.
It had no power.
And all it had was just
telecommunications software
that would run the serial
drivers for the serial port.
And there was a serial cable
connecting that dummy terminal
to a much more powerful Pentium
PC that was running Linux
so that I could effectively
do everything that anyone else
could do on Linux, which was
powerful but command line
text-based--
at least at that time and
still can largely be operated
in a text-based way--
operating system.
So I did that for
a bunch of years.
All the way through college
I was this weird guy who
had two computers, connected the
serial cable, only one monitor,
and it was like
this whole thing.
And then finally,
it got to a point
where I was going to go
interview for an internship.
And they were like, look.
This was in grad school.
I was going to go work
at a private equity fund.
It was a job while I
was in grad school.
It was more than internship.
And they said, look.
We can't work with
you like that.
You need to be able to
create Excel spreadsheets.
You need to be able
to do all this stuff.
So I said, OK.
Well then, I'm going
to have to learn
how to use Windows after all.
By that point, it
was Windows 2000.
Or it was maybe
almost Windows XP.
So I went and learned
how to use JAWS
for Windows, which is
the software that I still
somewhat use today.
I use it all the time
when I'm using a PC.
And so I kind of
had to learn that,
and I felt pretty disrupted
there, but I But learned it.
And right as I
was feeling pretty
good about PC solutions--
I had a laptop.
I remember I started
in law school in 2006,
and I was on the Metro
North from Yale to New York.
And I was using a laptop with
one of those portable modem
things in it and
using earphones.
It was great.
I was using Windows.
Then all of a sudden,
what happened?
The smartphone with
the touch screen--
not good, right?
Not good.
Not good for the blind, right?
So I shied away from using that.
And I mean, all
the way until a guy
who's here today who
helped put this on,
Mike Mello taught me in--
I remember it was
Halloween of 2010 or 2011.
I just remember that
it was Halloween,
because I remember I was
going to a Halloween party
that night.
He came and basically
showed me how
to use voiceover software
on the iPhone which had just
incorporated into
the most recent iOS
upgrade into the iPhone.
And then what happened was I
went from having been divided
from my peers by this technology
to not only catching up,
but the iPhone--
I've said this, and I will
now include Android devices.
But it was the iPhone that
brought the solution first--
for me was the greatest
civil rights innovation
since the Americans with
Disabilities Act for the blind.
Nothing has changed my life
more other than public policy
when it comes to overcoming
this disability than the iPhone
than having access
to a smartphone--
not only because it allowed me
to do things which we're all
now able to do in this
decade since the iPhone
and its competitors really
came out and do them
and be more efficient
the way all of you
are, but also because
so many solutions that
disproportionately
help the blind.
Can you think of one?
What's one thing that
for the time being,
blind people find it
really difficult to do?
Drive cars, right?
So if you were lucky enough
to be able to afford a taxi--
and I was a corporate
lawyer, so I could--
then if you were blind,
the distinct pleasure
of having to wait 20 minutes
for a taxi to come and hope
that the cab driver would be
able to first of all actually
make it to you.
And then you couldn't
communicate with them,
so you'd have to hope
that they would just
figure out who you are.
But most likely, they would
pick someone else up on the way
or think it's someone else
or someone hails them down,
and then you got to call
again on your regular phone.
And so it was like
a total nightmare.
If you were taking the bus,
it was even worse, right?
Because if you didn't
have access to--
so now we have Uber.
But if you were
taking the bus, you
didn't have access to OneBusAway
or any of the other apps,
and so you were really
set adrift in so many ways
disproportionately.
And so whether it's
wayfinding technologies--
and I know that with the
impact grants that Google
has been given, I know
that's an area where
I think Google Maps and
others are working together
on wayfinding solutions
for the blind.
By the way, I'm
talking about blindness
because that's
what I know about.
Obviously, disability
and accessibility
is a much bigger topic,
but you can extrapolate.
So then the smartphone
kind of became the thing
and allowed me not only to
catch up but also actually
disproportionately to
benefit I would say compared
to the typical population.
I'm really excited that the
most recent user interface
innovation that came
about essentially
seems to have been
developed by blind people,
because it's just like a
random cylinder with no screen
that you just talk to.
I'm, of course, talking
about the Google
Home, not any of our other
hometown competitors.
I did, of course, take
note earlier this year
when Amazon came out
with the Echo Look show--
there's a few of them--
with a screen on it.
And I was like, all right,
so this will happen again.
But it's OK, in large part
because of the interest
and knowledge and skills
that people in this room
and your counterparts at
Microsoft, Amazon, and Apple.
I always give special
recognition to Apple,
because this has been part of
their culture from day one.
Because of you and
your counterparts,
the lag time between the
disruption and the rescue
has shrunk.
But here's what I think is more
interesting than all of that.
And before I do
that, let me say--
the implications
of this are huge,
because it's not just that I get
to know when the bus is coming
or call an Uber or whatever
or find my way around.
But the implications for
employment for people
with disabilities are massive.
For one thing, OneBusAway helps
people with disabilities to get
to work just like it helps
everybody to get to work--
disproportionately helps
people with disabilities to get
to work--
which is an important
part of working
is actually getting
to and from the job.
The ability to use a
smartphone, tablets,
and other mobile platforms
allows people with disabilities
to graduate from
entry level jobs
to more sophisticated jobs.
But overall, it's
my great privilege
as lieutenant governor to
travel around the state and even
the country and brag
about this region.
And what I say is that Amazon,
Microsoft, and Google--
all three have your
cloud computing
and much of your other
fourth Industrial Revolution
technologies, big data,
AI, machine learning,
internet of things--
have a lot of these
operations headquartered here.
Amazon and Microsoft
obviously, but even Google
is growing your
cloud-based operations here
in the Pacific Northwest.
Well, why is that important
to this discussion?
Because as you
create the solutions
that your customers are using--
that they're creating and that
other customers are using--
you have the ability to make
not only services, not only
software, but entire platforms,
entire systems accessible out
of the box, which is
going to have such
a huge impact on the
ability of people
to find employment, the ability
of people of all abilities
to be able to live the quality
of life that we all deserve.
But I want to go
beyond all that,
which is to say that's
all about accommodating.
That's all about accommodating
people with disabilities,
and it's the right thing to do.
In a lot of cases when we
get it right, it's the law.
Congress passed the CVAA-- the
21st Century Communications
and Video accessibility Act--
in 2010 to add on to the
ADA in the space in which I
imagine many of you work, which
is the communications space.
So there are statutes,
there are regulations,
and those are good when
it comes to accommodating.
But I actually think that
what's more important for us
to get the significance
of this evangelized
throughout
organizations as large
as Google is to talk about the
upside business proposition.
Now, in part, that's the one in
five people with disabilities
in this country who you
also don't want to write out
as part of your customer base.
But let me tell you something
that I said to Microsoft folks
much like you guys, and I
just wanted to be provocative.
This is more of a salient
point to Microsoft
than it is to
Google, but I think
it applies some degree
to a number of companies.
So what I said to
them was I said, look.
Do you believe that the
technology behind Siri--
do you believe that
that was not doable
before Siri five years earlier?
Do you believe the technology
behind Alexa and the Amazon
Echo and other products
and now Google Home--
do you believe that it couldn't
have been done, that everyone
was on the same page
that this is something
we need to do but they just
never got around or couldn't
get the technology together?
And I said, you know, what
I believe is that speech
recognition software--
and I got a chance to meet Ray
Kurzweil, who's a hero of mine,
just a few weeks
ago in New York.
Speech recognition software was
for people with disabilities
primarily.
Having output like Siri and
Alexa and Google Home do--
that was for people
with disabilities,
because everyone else
could read the screen.
So it would be weird.
Why would you have
this thing talk to you?
It didn't make any sense.
You can read the screen.
That's how everyone
was thinking.
Problem is that when we think
about how to be innovative,
the hardest thing is to try
to think outside our own box.
This has been something
Microsoft's particularly
struggled with.
But I will say,
as Google becomes
more and more of
a legacy company,
it's something Google's
got to think about too.
You get comfortable.
You've got some good products.
You're cash rich.
You're acquisitory
in some good ways.
You make partnerships.
The paradigms get set in stone.
I don't know, but I imagine
it's probably quite challenging
to come and try to do search
in a completely different way
at a company like Google.
The search and the ad ecosystem
that lies on top of it's
been such a critical
part of Google's success,
and it's Google's cash cow--
the ad business.
Let me say this-- but when
you think about someone
with a disability and
how they do things,
as soon as you do that, you
are in a different space.
You are already in
a creative space.
You're already in
an innovative space,
because you got to think
completely differently.
You got to completely
disrupt your own assumptions
about the best way to display
information or the best way
to take in a request.
So what I told them was, look.
I bet you, Microsoft.
If you guys had actually said
back when Windows 95 came out,
let's figure out the
best and most logical
way for people who are
blind to use Windows--
not just like, let's get
some third party developer.
We'll share the
libraries with them.
We'll have them
develop something
so that you can have a blind
person going to limp along
on top of Windows and
try to approximate,
but actually tear it all up
and say, how would we do this?
Yeah, it's expensive.
It's more expensive to do it
that way, even if it's legal
and you won't get sued.
But like it's expensive
to do it that way.
You might think that there's
not that many blind people,
so I get why you may
not want to do that
from a short-term
economic perspective.
But I bet you if you did that,
you would have beaten apple
to the market on Siri.
And I bet you if you did
that, you'd have beaten Amazon
to the market on Alexa.
You know how hard it is
for people at Microsoft
to hear those kind of words?
These people get to
elect or unelect me,
so it's not an easy thing
to say to everybody.
I truly believe-- and
you can correct me--
but I truly believe that
when you wait for innovations
to happen by serendipity, it
will take longer than if you
follow what I believe to be a
sure-proof way of developing
new innovative solutions, which
is think about whatever you're
doing now and then
think about how
people of all different
abilities or disabilities
would want to accomplish
the same task.
The minute you do that,
you will be creative.
And it will have all types
of unforeseen positive
consequences.
People often talk about
the curb-cut effect.
The people made wheelchair
ramps for people in wheelchairs.
But then if we didn't
need wheelchairs anymore,
we wouldn't get
rid of curb cuts,
because everyone in this room
has used them for one purpose
or another-- stroller,
suitcase, whatever.
So that effect is
true, but it is
I think particularly true if
the business that you're in
is competitive and the
fault lines of competition
are around innovation
and imagination.
So thinking about people with
abilities and disabilities
is not just the right thing
to do for the market share
that you will gain in
users but the right thing
to do if you want to come out
with the next game-changing
innovation for everybody.
And I promise you that there
are innovations out there
right now that if you all
were thinking about how
to make your products
and services more
available to the deaf, to
people with cerebral palsy,
to people with dementia maybe--
I mean, I'm serious.
If you start
thinking about it, I
bet you you're going to learn
new things about memory,
new things about
kinetic technologies,
and how the internet of things
can move to the next level.
So that's what I want
to share with you all--
is my personal story of how
technology has both disrupted
and rescued me over time, how
it's done that in the wider
society, and the particular--
not responsibility,
because that's so boring and
nanny stateish, but actual
economic opportunity for
everyone here and everyone
at Google from Larry Page on
down to make money and create
new innovations by thinking
not about those with disability
as an afterthought
but having that
be a core part of a
multi-ability approach
towards product design
and development.
So with that, I will
end my mansplaining
or politiciansplaining remarks
telling you how to do your job,
and I'm happy to answer any
questions that you guys have.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Thanks for the talk.
So I used to work in
government contractor,
and this was back when
the section 508 of the ADA
was first--
CYRUS HABIB:
Rehabilitations Act.
AUDIENCE: Right, right.
So one of the core
tenants of that
is that all government procured
software had to have compliance
with the Rehabilitation Act,
and there was a lot of effort
put in the time to bring systems
to that level of compliance.
And I remember using
JAWS screen reader myself
to go through and
test the application
to make sure that it
was working or not
and usable with only
the audio interface.
And I was wondering--
over the past decade,
how has the landscape
changed both in terms of
government-procured software
and the private industry
for smaller companies
in making their applications
accessible and usable?
CYRUS HABIB: Yeah, I mean,
that's why I mentioned mobile.
Because mobile is so
much a part of how we all
do our computing and our
communications, et cetera.
And so iPhone, iOS, Android,
increasingly Windows--
to the extent these technologies
have become accessible
natively, it's
made it all better.
I'm sure it is the case--
I know it's the case--
that app developers have to
think about and get input
from the community.
But it's so much easier when
the operating system developers
have themselves already
thought about how applications
on this platform are
going to interact
with this
accessibility solution.
So for those who
don't know, I don't
know how it works with Android.
I hate to say it--
iPhone user.
But for the iPhone, for
example, the way it works
is you touch the screen.
And rather than selecting that
item, it reads you that item.
And then you would double tap
on it to actually select it--
so in that sense, kind of
analogous to a graphical user
interface with a mouse.
And then there's some other
reconfigured keystrokes or hand
gestures that Apple itself--
which is constantly
in communication
with the community,
and I'm sure Google is.
I've heard great things
about Android too.
And so that just alleviates most
of the pressure on developers.
There's still issues, right?
Sometimes it's really
things, for example,
like CAPTCHA challenges
and things like that.
Sometimes it's very
simple things like that.
And then websites-- the
display of information
on websites when
they're embedded
in graphics and things.
I mean, there's still issues
that the operating system can't
necessarily address or the
web browser can't necessarily
address, but they've gotten
so much better at doing it.
Even recognition and photo
descriptions and things
like that is great.
Government procurement-- I
think government does the best
job that it can, but it's not
like there are a ton of options
for most solutions sets.
So usually you need an
enterprise solution,
and here are your choices.
And so that's why working
with these big four companies
is so important.
AUDIENCE: So I have
two questions for you.
I guess the line is OK, so
I'll ask my two questions.
The first question is, if
you don't speak English,
do you think your life
would have been much worse?
For example, if I think of
health bills for example,
they always have a page that
have a billion languages on it
saying here's your right.
We can provide
interpreter for you
to have your own language so
you can understand the bill,
but that's all printed.
And so if you're blind, I
don't know what happened there.
So that's my first
question-- is if you
don't speak English how your
life would have been affected.
CYRUS HABIB: Do you mean--
sorry-- how my life would be
with respect to technology
or with respect to--
AUDIENCE: In general?
CYRUS HABIB: If I
didn't speak English?
AUDIENCE: Right.
But if you want, you
can also particularly
in technology if
that's what you want.
CYRUS HABIB: Do I get to
speak another language,
or do I just lose English?
AUDIENCE: Let's say you
do speak another language.
CYRUS HABIB: OK.
What's your second question?
AUDIENCE: My second question is,
do you ever use a cheat sheet
or prep sheet when
you give public talk
or similar assistive thing to
help you with remembering what
you're going to talk about?
CYRUS HABIB: Is that your way
of saying that my remarks are
scattered and disorganized?
That's OK.
AUDIENCE: It's more like I
didn't know you weren't--
CYRUS HABIB: What about a
hybrid question where it's like,
what if you don't speak
English and you need
a cheat sheet for your speech?
[LAUGHTER]
I think that-- again,
smaller concentric circle,
but still would be a
cool technology for you
guys to develop.
I think when it
comes to-- look, I
don't know enough
about being blind.
I got the chance to visit
a school for the blind
in Seoul, South Korea, which was
really cool a couple of months
ago and talked to
those students.
But I don't know enough
about the solutions
that are out there.
The accessibility solutions
that are out there
vary from place to place.
I do know that there is Braille
in all different languages.
We should not
forget that Braille
wasn't developed by an English
speaker, so that does exist.
And so where there's
Braille, there's
the ability to do
Braille printing.
And I know that there
are screen readers
in a number of
different languages
for a whole bunch of
geopolitical reasons.
Farsi, which is the language
that my parents first spoke,
is probably going to
be one of the tougher
ones for a population that
large for a bunch of reasons
having to do with
trade sanctions.
But there's no doubt
that even if it were just
living in the US
but in a rural area,
I would have more challenges.
I feel very lucky
to have grown up
in an environment that's just--
I grew up just a couple of
miles from Bill Gates's home.
So clearly when new
innovations would come out,
we had the wherewithal and the
knowledge and awareness of it
to do it.
And clearly, Google--
it was interesting,
because I did spend a couple
of months working on Middle
East sales for Google.
I know that growing
overseas is huge.
But obviously, you
guys and everyone
test your products
out in English first.
Those solutions come to
market first in English,
so that's definitely a big
advantage for all of us.
But increasingly, you
have major tech disruptors
out there and tech companies--
Tencent and Alibaba and
others-- and so there'll
be new solutions that will
originate from those places
and those companies.
So I don't have any
kind of a cheat sheet.
I could have things Brailled
for me and have them with me
or have a Braille display.
By the way, just so you
guys know, one of the things
I do as lieutenant governor
is I serve as president
of the State Senate.
So I preside over
the State Senate.
Part of that job is
calling on senators
when they want to speak, and
because they are politicians,
they always want to speak.
And so we had to figure out,
OK, how do we make that happen?
Because when people
stand up, how
am I going to know
who wants to speak?
Well, we developed a solution
where state senators have
a touch screen on their desk,
and when they want to speak,
they stand up and touch
the screen on their desk.
And it sends their
name up to a PC that's
operating right up where I
am at the front of the Senate
chamber, and then
it sends their name
on to a Braille
display in real time
so I can call on
senators as they speak.
So if you guys come to Olympia,
would love to show it to you.
And if you're
struggling with amnesia
and you watch TVW
channel 23 at night,
you can see me presiding
over the State Senate
and putting that
technology to use.
So I do sometimes
use technologies
in those kind of situations.
Up there I do have
Braille so that I
know which bills that we're
doing, which legislation we're
considering, but I
don't for speeches.
And I probably wouldn't if
I could see, because I just
think it's better to speak
naturally to you guys
and have a
conversational approach,
even if it's a big speech.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thank you.
CYRUS HABIB: Any
other questions?
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
There's a line now.
So first of all, thank you
so much for taking the time
to come and address
us this afternoon.
I am speaking to you as
the very proud mother
of two boys on IEPs who have
developmental disabilities.
And as you yourself
experienced, technology
is such an amazing difference
when it comes to their ability
to access the general
education curriculum
and to be included in gen ed.
And yet because of funding
and inadequate funding growth,
especially as things like
autism have exploded,
there has not been
sufficient funding
to be able to give them
that kind of an opportunity
so that they can
also go to Yale.
So what is being done
in Olympia to address
that in the short term?
CYRUS HABIB: To
my mind, because I
had the benefit of a 24 hour a
day pro bono attorney as a kid.
That's my mom-- like you,
fierce advocate for her son.
That question that you asked
is the one that both motivates
me and disturbs and haunts me.
Notice that when I--
I don't know if you were here
when I first started out,
but I said first,
parents, second,
a reasonably well-funded
public school district.
And it's absolutely critical.
It's why smaller class
sizes are important.
It's why funding all day
kindergarten is important.
So the larger education spending
that we do disproportionately
helps kids with disabilities.
But over and above
that, the underfunding
of special education to my mind
means that we're not there yet
when it comes to our
constitutional duty
in this state for
basic education.
We're not there yet on our
statutory responsibilities
under the IDEA and
state laws, and so I
think parents should 100%--
first of all, legislators
should do the right thing
in the first place.
But sometimes, litigation
is a part of that
and lawsuits have happened,
and they'll continue to happen.
And I think that's an
important part of the system,
because kids need to--
stories of kids who
were not getting access
to the kind of assistance that
they need, the support they
need to be able to fulfill
their full potential.
Those stories need to get heard.
And if they're not heard
in legislative offices,
they need to be
heard in courtrooms.
And so it's extremely important.
It's extremely important.
AUDIENCE: Appreciate
all of your help.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I actually
would like to thank you
for coming in and addressing
us this afternoon.
I found what you said both
interesting and inspiring,
particularly in my case, because
I work on a user experience
team.
So we're very much focused on
how to make things work better
for all kinds of people.
I started at Microsoft back
in the windows 2.0 days.
And I remember very clearly
how much it came as a shock
to us to learn that people with
visual disabilities loathed us,
because Windows had
disrupted their ability
to use computers so much.
And I was wondering if you see
any emerging technologies that
might prove to be as equally
disruptive for people
with both visual and
other disabilities
that we should be
watching out for.
CYRUS HABIB: You should not--
I appreciate the question, but
you're asking the wrong person.
You should be asking
your colleagues,
and those colleagues
should have disabilities.
So that's the
single best way you
get the right answer to that
question, because I don't know,
nor do you want me to know.
Because if I know, it
means Amazon knows, right?
So you don't want me to know
what technologies you guys are
about to come out with.
And by when you bring
it out, it's too late.
It's not too late,
but it's late, right?
So you want your trade secrets
to remain your trade secrets.
You want your project names,
secret names to remain secret,
and you want to do
what you're doing.
But you want to have the
bench depth of people
with all different abilities so
that those questions are being
asked-- and again, not just
because you want to figure out,
well, we're developing.
We want to connect YouTube to
the Google Homes or whatever,
right-- whatever new thing
you guys are going to do.
Not just like, well,
how do we make sure
that people who are blind can
do that, but rather, OK, what
is it about how a blind
person would want to receive
that information
that would actually
be interesting for others?
I don't know.
This didn't happen this
way, but I mean, one thing--
I think back to Google search.
And when Google search
came out compared to Yahoo
and compared to Altavista and
Lycos and all the other search
engines that have gone
the way of the dinosaur,
one thing that was
unique about Google
from a user
experience perspective
was how stripped down
and simple it was.
It was extremely low--
it's a big deal when Google will
put a holiday thing on there,
because it's like such
a bare-bones thing.
Whereas Yahoo and these other
things were using search--
really, embedding search
into what they hoped
would be kind of
like a home page
for a bunch of other things.
Now when you go
to Google search,
you've got news, mail,
YouTube, whatever,
but it's still
relatively bare-bones.
Not as much as it used
to be, but it still is.
Now, that's something that--
it didn't happen because
a blind person said,
that makes it
easier to navigate.
It does make it easier for
blind people to navigate,
but it also has other
market value with respect
to non-blind people.
So again, I would say that
question that you're asking--
you should both ask
it of people that
are your colleagues
who then would be
well-positioned to answer it.
But then you should also ask the
complementary question, which
is, which alternative
user experiences
should we metastasize outside
the disability context
into a broader
use case scenario?
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: It makes
a lot of sense.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Have you tried VR?
CYRUS HABIB: Me?
I'm down.
I'm ready.
But there's a great example next
generation technologies that
could unite, that could
divide, that could rescue,
that could disrupt.
But in any case, look.
People with disabilities
already live
in realities that have different
sensory dimensions to them,
so why anyone would
develop an AR,
VR platform without
having people
with sensory disabilities
right in the room
makes no sense to me.
And I think failure to do that--
it doesn't mean the
end of the world,
but I do think it will mean
a delay in getting products
and solutions to market.
Because there is no doubt
that with the technology
that Google has and
had in 2005, 2006--
you all could have done
the Echo back then.
You know that.
You know you could have
done Siri back then.
I mean, of course you could
have, but it was weird.
Why would someone
who can see ever
want to use that kind of thing?
So again, I think the AR,
VR is a great use case
for the proposition
that I'm making here.
AUDIENCE: So thanks so
much for being here today.
I don't quite
follow your argument
about things having been
able to be done back then.
For example, Arthur C.
Clarke, Isaac Asimov--
these concepts of
robot units that
can answer your
question off hand
have been available
for a very long time,
so I'm not following.
And they were thought
of in some cases
by people who were trying to
envision what the world would
be like by others who couldn't
work that way in various--
CYRUS HABIB: Right,
but they were never--
but it costs money to take it
a Las Vegas Expo and even more
so from the pages of a science
fiction book or a futurist TED
Talk.
It takes money to get it
from there to something
that you can hold in your hands.
So yes, it's not like the
idea of Alexa or Cortana
or Google Home or Siri--
it's not like any of these were
not thought of before, right?
I mean, look.
The internet of things,
the smart home--
you guys remember.
You could go to Redmond,
and they had one in '98.
So they knew it, right?
But so much of the
technologies that ended up
making it possible and
desirable were ones
that you'd have to be
sensory deprived to think
were innovative.
Why isn't there a screen?
Because everyone's idea was
the best way to get information
is from a screen.
The best way to input
information is with your hands,
and so you'll do
it with keystrokes.
But no-- that's a moving part.
Then you go to a mouse.
OK, that's object-oriented.
That's an improvement.
It's still a moving part.
How about a touch screen?
OK, but you're still
using your hands.
So the idea that you
would use your mouth
to input information--
it wasn't that they
hadn't thought of it.
Of course people had thought of
it, but it was not desirable.
It wasn't viewed as marketable,
because it was like, well,
who's doing that--
just some paraplegic?
Who can't use their hands
to use a touch screen?
It's the easiest thing ever.
So that's my point.
It's not a lack, I think, of
technological imagination.
I think it's a lack of
business case imagination.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
CYRUS HABIB: But I want
people to disagree with me,
because it's like nothing's
more offensive to me
than when people come
in and tell me how
the legislative process works.
So I'm sure some of you
find it really irritating
that this know-it-all
who took my last math
class in 12th grade
is telling you
guys what you could or
couldn't have done or whatever.
Tell me that I'm wrong.
AUDIENCE: All right.
I'm only asking this question
because nobody else is up here.
Ever since I saw your
first campaign sign
after I moved to this area,
I have a really good friend
from grad school who
has a son named Cyrus.
And when we looked at the sign,
I looked my wife, and I said,
do you think he pronounces
it "see-roos" or "sigh-rus?"
Because my friend
who has a kid named
Cyrus is a Farsi name
or a Persian name.
And so now you're
here, so now I want
to ask you so I can
settle this with my wife.
CYRUS HABIB: I would say it
depends on which language
I'm speaking.
So if I'm speaking Farsi,
then you would say "see-roos."
And if I'm speaking English,
I would say "sigh-rus,"
because that's the English
language pronunciation.
Just like if you're
speaking Spanish,
you would say "meh-hi-co,"
if you're speaking English,
you'd say Mexico.
And from my
perspective, that's OK.
It's OK to use either one.
It's OK to use both.
AUDIENCE: We were just curious.
There's no right answer.
CYRUS HABIB: Yeah.
I'll tell you, Miley
Cyrus was a big help.
The thing is, it's more that
you want people to know how
to spell it when they hear it.
That's a bigger problem
than knowing how
to say it when they read it.
So the problem that I want
to solve for is when I say,
email me at cyrush@gmail.com--
S-I-R, whatever, right?
So if I said "See-rus," that
would just really throw people
off. .
I like to build off of the name
equity if not necessarily brand
equity that Miley Cyrus has
built in pronouncing that name.
It is the case that Cyrus and
this kind of similarly sibilant
name Silas--
you like how I did
that right there?
It was very meta what
I did right there.
Similarly sibilant
name Silas tend
to be the names of villains
in a lot of movies,
so just think about it.
Are there any other questions?
No other questions?
OK.
I'll be around.
I think we'll be around
for a couple more minutes,
and then I'm heading out.
You know where to find
me on social media,
and now you know how to
spell @cyrushabib or @waltgov
on Twitter and on
Facebook, et cetera.
So look forward to being in
touch with anybody who wants
to talk about these things.
And in closing, I will just
say that the single best
thing that anyone can
do here above and beyond
the substantive engineering
work that you're doing
is to help to build an HR
culture that will allow there
to be-- because there's nothing
about the job of lieutenant
governor that says that I
need to come in and give tech
companies ideas on
how to build products.
The best thing is to hire
people with all different sorts
of personal stories and
experiences and abilities
into the company to enrich and
enliven the user base right
here and to help you all imagine
what the future can look like.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]